AGREEMENT THAT BENEFIT HIS
ESTATE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THREATENED
TO KILL THE DEAL IF IT'S NOT
ADJUSTED TO PROTECT AMERICAN
WORKERS.
EPA CHIEF SCOTT PRUITT SAYS HE
IS UNDER POLITICAL ATTACK
BECAUSE OF HIS EFFECTIVENESS AND
PUSHING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONSERVATIVE AGENDA.
PRUITT HAS BEEN TAKING HEAVY
CRITICISM OVER ISSUES INVOLVING
EXPENSES AND JUDGMENT.
HE TALKED EXCLUSIVELY TODAY WITH
FOX NEWS CHIEF NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY.
>> THE LATEST TROUBLE FOR EPA
CHIEF SCOTT PRUITT IS A REPORT
CHARGING HE AND HIS TEAM
DEMANDED BIG PAY RAISES FOR TWO
LONGTIME POLITICAL ADVISORS.
AFTER AIDS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID IT WAS A WASTE OF TAXPAYER
MONEY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
IGNORED IT AND APPROVE THE PAY
HIKES, INCLUDING ONE FOR
$36,000.
IN AN OCCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
FOX, HE CLAIMS HE WAS IN THE
DARK.
>> IF YOU ARE COMMITTED TO THE
TRUMP AGENDA, WHY DID YOU GO TO
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND GIVE PAY
RACES?
>> I DID NOT.
MY FAST STAFF DID.
>> THAT SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
DONE.
THEY WILL BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> CAREER PERSON OR POLITICAL
PERSON?
>> I DON'T KNOW DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHO DID IT?
>> I FOUND OUT IT YESTERDAY AND
I CORRECTED THE ACTION.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF FINDING
OUT HOW WHAT TOOK PLACE.
>> THE ATLANTIC CHARGE OF THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND HIS TEAM
FILED A FORMAL APPLICATION FOR
THE RAISES.
WHEN TOLD NO, PRUITT FOUND A
POSITION AND THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER ACT THAT LET HIM DO
IT.
A MATTER NOW UNDER WHITE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PRAISED PRUITT
FOR CUTTING GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS.
IT BOOSTED THE ECONOMY AND SAVED
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
THE CHIEF OF STAFF JOHN KELLY IS
ALSO ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
REPORTS OF PRUITT TAKING AN
EXPENSIVE OFFICIAL TRIP TO
MOROCCO AND FRANCE AND
CONSIDERING, BUT ULTIMATELY
DECLINING, WHETHER IT WAS A GOOD
IDEA TO SPEND $100,000 A MONTH
TO LEASE A PRIVATE JET.
PLUS QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE PROVED PRUITT RENTED
PART OF A WASHINGTON CONDO FROM
A LOBBYIST AT THE BELOW MARKET
RATE FOR $50 A NIGHT, LEAD FOUR
CALLS FOR HIM TO RESIGN OR BE
FIRED.
CARLOS CURBELO SANG HIS
CORRUPTION IS EMBARRASSING.
WHILE HE GOT A LUKEWARM
ASSESSMENT TODAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE ARE REVIEWING THE
SITUATION.
WE HAVE HAD THE CHANCE TO HAVE A
DEEPER DIVE ON IT, WE'LL LET YOU
KNOW THE OUTCOMES.
>> PRUITT BLAME TO THE LEFT FOR
TARGETING HIM BECAUSE HE
SAYS HE IS A CONSERVATIVE
SUCCESSFUL AT SHAKING UP
WASHINGTON.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WOULD
DRAIN THE SWAMP.
HE'S DRAINING THE SWAMP RENTING
AN APARTMENT FROM THE WIFE OF A
WASHINGTON LOBBYIST?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT IS EVEN
REMOTELY FAIR TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
>> PRUITT REPEATEDLY DUCKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER HE'S
MADE MISTAKES HIMSELF.
HE PASSED IT MULTIPLE CHANCES TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANY OF
THESE TROUBLES.